oh it's fun to go to the beach in the  convertible well I want to show you a  guy who went to the beach and the jet  platt back he's a real-life Ironman and  in doing so he shattered a Guinness  World Record there he goes  British inventor Richard browning went  85 miles an hour in his jet suit that's  more than double the speed of the  previous record that he also set two  years ago new record was achieved at  Brighton Pier in England browning plans  to launch a series of jet suits for  competitive racing this thing was  actually made entirely 3d printed it has  five guest turbines that produce over a  thousand brake horsepower to gain flight  look at that thing honestly is it legal  it'll commute that way in New York City  because I'll do it tomorrow I know I was  like it looks really handy right hey  doesn't look I would never do it it  doesn't looks okay I want to put the  wrong arm hole in that one though right  could be a problem